pero cosmonautas rusos a bordo de la
estación espacial internacional una
realidad desde hace más de 20 años pero
pronto la imagen pertenecerá al pasado
es lo que anunció el nuevo jefe de la
agencia espacial rusa durante una
conversación con vladímir putin en el
kremlin
sin duda cumpliremos todas nuestras
obligaciones con nuestros socios pero la
decisión de dejar la estación después de
2024 está tomada
la nasa asegura que no ha sido
notificada oficialmente de la retirada
de rusia después de 2024
la estación espacial internacional es
una de las pocas cooperaciones que aún
existen entre moscú y washington en el
lado ruso ya se están preparando para el
futuro la nueva prioridad para el
programa espacial nacional una estación
orbital rusa que podría parecerse a esto
y creo que para entonces empezaremos a
crear una estación orbital rusa azul
afectado por las fuertes sanciones
occidentales de los últimos meses y la
corrupción generalizada el sector
aerospacial ruso se encuentra según las
propias autoridades en una situación
difícil esto contrasta con china que
debería completar su propia estación
espacial a finales de año una hazaña
tecnológica lograda por pekín en menos
de dos años